I lost money I lost money for myself I
lost money for my clients I had to let
everybody in my company go and I had to
I was so broke I had to borrow $4,000
from my Dad wow pay some of my family
bills so I mean I was it it it it was a
lot of pain what it gave me was the
humility that I needed to balance with
my audacity it gave me that fear of
being wrong and that fear of being wrong
gave me an open mind
I came to view problems like Puzzles and
the puzzles were what would I do
differently in the future so I wouldn't
make that painful mistake and you either
have an epiphany or you don't now you
either walk off the field and say hey I
don't want to do this anymore and you
give up on that going after your
audacious goals or you gain really
humility you you know how do you feel
that you're going to be wrong pain plus
reflection equals progress pain teaches
you about how reality works I mean how
do you improve when you have to be
believe that you're perfect all the time